One other way to see people's real characters where they tell the truth about
the powerful or whether they suck up to the powerful today,
over an MSNBC on their morning show everybody nodded in bovine agreement.
Well,
a world health organization official gushed about the fascist government of
China. Watch this.
Right now. There's very,
very few countries that have actually been able to reverse this, uh, this, um,
uh, epidemic and bring their case to down to very low level. And in fact,
the only country that has done that as China, it was, um, the passion,
the diligence, the sense of responsibility,
the seriousness of the average Chinese.
And I want to use that term very carefully because they weren't average.
They were extraordinary people,
but they were driven by a sense of collective responsibility.
Dave Rubin hosts the Rubin report on YouTube. He joins us tonight.
He may not be aware, Dave Rubin,
that these are extraordinary people driven by a sense of collective
responsibility. They're your moral superiors. They're doing the right thing.
Unlike America. How do you assess that claim about China?
Well, collective is the key word. There. They are a collectivist society.
We are an individualist society, but specifically here, uh, you know,
authoritarians love authoritarianism, meaning they love central planning.
They love the idea that the state can control everything.
That's actually the reverse of the American ethos.
Now neither system is absolutely perfect,
but I personally wouldn't want to trade in my rights and my Liberty
and my free speech and all of those things to have a system of government that
could always tell me what to do.
Freedom is a little bit messy and we have to fight that and negotiate that with
the people that would take our freedoms away all the time. Uh,
so what's particularly interesting here though, is that,
you know what they're saying,
basically is give all of your freedoms to the state and then the state can
somehow do everything, right? Except what they forget is the backend of that.
And the backend of that is you, you count people into silence,
you give away your freedoms and, uh,
and you end up living in a place that most of us wouldn't want to live,
which is why Americans don't leave because we got a pretty good.
They're praising.
They're praising a government that harvest the organs from murdered political
prisoners. Should that make us nervous?
Of course it should make us nervous.
But the idea is the same people who want to import or authoritarian ideas
here are the same people that love those ideas elsewhere.
So they never talk about the bad things, right?
They're not going to talk about the bad things about communism on MSNBC because
they kind of like it, right? So they slowly, they tell you the good things, Oh,
in times of crisis, they've been able to organize in a certain way.
Now that's also,
if you're going to really believe the numbers coming out of China and everything
else. So it's hard to figure out what's true right now. And I, again,
freedom is the key thing.
What we're all having to do right now is decide how much freedom do we want to
give away in the midst of a crisis.
And that's an important debate to have it's when you've been having quite well
on this show, actually.
Well, we're trying, there's so much going on Dave and great to see you tonight.
Thank you.
Thanks Tucker.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.